all right hi everybody and welcome back
to the channel my name is Bradley Knapp
and I'm one of the product managers here
at IBM cloud and what I want to talk
with you guys about today is a question
that we get fairly commonly when folks
are starting their cloud journey and
starting to learn about cloud and that's
what is is I read about cloud I see this
I ass thing everywhere what does it
actually mean and so I as is an acronym
right and so it's broken into two parts
the first part the I that's
infrastructure and so if you think of
cloud as being just some other dudes
computer running somewhere else that's
the infrastructure part and so that
infrastructure if it's not cloud it
could be running in a data center
somewhere you can be running in a closet
somewhere your laptop of your desktop is
infrastructure and then the AAS piece is
as a service right that's the billing
method that's the way that you consume
it and there are other kinds of as a
service you've got pads platform as a
service you have SAS software as a
service there's lots of different kinds
of things that you can consume as a
service but very specifically what we
want to talk about is the I it's the
infrastructure and so I've got this
diagram written out over here because
infrastructure really falls into three
main categories right the first category
is going to be compute that's where the
processors are that's where the actual
lifting and computing gets done the
second piece which is storage kind of
falls into three main buckets and lots
of smaller buckets on top of it because
there's different kinds of storage and
then the third piece the piece that ties
everything together
that's our network piece and so we're
gonna draw this one over here because
without network you can't do anything
network is how the compute talks to the
storage and that's how the compute talks
to the other compute and so like I said
we can break this down into different
place different pieces and so in the
compute side I've got three things
called out up here the first one is kind
of I've just got a labeled compute its
general purpose computer right this is
your normal web server or application
server it can really be whatever general
purpose kind of computing needs you have
the second two are or the second and the
third really are more specific right so
GPU is
is a graphics processor that's a very
very high speed processor that's used in
conjunction with a traditional processor
for specific kinds of workloads right
this is gonna be your machine learning
in your AI and then the third piece HPC
that's high-performance computing so
there's specific kinds of workloads that
had very specific requirements as far as
frequency which is your clock speed and
the number of cores that are required
where you have to have lots of power
packed into a very very very small
footprint that's gonna be your HPC and
likewise on the storage side you've got
different kinds of storage because you
have different storage needs the most
commonly used one is gonna be object
storage object storage is a little bit
lower performance but it's relatively
inexpensive and that's for your general
purpose storage right what goes into
object storage well you can have things
like pictures you can have documents you
can have really whatever you want can go
into that object storage it's where all
of the data and all of the graphics on
the web server that's all hitting hiding
in object storage and then the second
and the third piece that I've got called
out here block and file these are
specific kinds of storage specific kinds
of network storage and they attach in
very specific ways block storage
attaches with I scuzzy file storage
attaches with NFS it's the way that they
mount into the actual compute itself and
there are specific kinds of applications
that require block storage or file
storage because each of them has their
own features and benefits and so to talk
about how we pull all of these things
together we need to talk about the
network because network has two main
components that matter and so what I
want you to do is I want you to think of
your network as a pipe right and so a
network can be a small pipe that would
be like a pipe measured in megabits so
you can't press much data through it or
it can be a very large pipe that very
large pipe that would be measured in
gigabits per second and so the more data
you need to push simultaneously the
larger pipe you need and the more
bandwidth you need the second way that
we measure network traffic is how much
data gets pushed through this pipe over
a set period of time normally it's
billed by the
month but it could also be billed by the
minute by the second or maybe even by
the day or by the week and so to take
all of this and tie all this together I
want to use an example of something that
requires some specialty components right
we're going to talk a little bit about
an AI workload and so if you think about
an AI workload where you're going to do
automatic visual recognition of pictures
let's say that you have a billion
pictures down here in object storage
that you are then going to use to train
your model that's running on these GPU
servers and so you take that billion
pictures and since a billion is a lot
and pictures are very large you have to
push them through a really big pipe at
your network pipe up into the GPU server
but the GPU server doesn't have any
storage inherent to it so that GPU
server is actually going to take and
write that into block and it's going to
write that data back and forth and back
and forth until the model is done once
it's trained it's going to take all of
the data that we pushed up here and all
of the results and it's going to write
all of that back down into object
storage Y and object storage because
again it's less expensive it's a good
archiving solution and so you're pushing
a ton of data through these pipes while
they're turned on and then what you're
done you get rid of them and so the
second piece that I want to talk about
is the as a service piece this is the
way that you consume and so when we talk
about as a service there are kind of
four things that really really matter in
this model and the first one is that
offerings that are consumed as a service
are generally speaking shared and so by
shared I mean they're multi-tenant many
people use the same offering we just
take and carve it up and make it
available to multiple different
customers simultaneously so that's the
first piece of as a service the second
piece is the hourly or monthly piece
this is talking about how we bill on the
in the case of compute it could be a
certain number of cents or certain of
dollars per hour or per month in the
case of storage we would bill out in the
amount of data that's stored in a given
month so that would be cents per
gigabyte per month in the case of
network there are two different metrics
we
about earlier right the size of the pipe
you would pay per month charge for that
and then the amount of data that goes
through it again measured in gigabytes
per month or cents per gigabytes per
month so that's our billing metric and
then the third piece and this is a very
important one is that there are no
contracts involved in an as a service
model or there aren't necessarily
contracts there can certainly be them
but they're generally advantageous to
you buy no contracts we mean that you
don't have to agree to use something for
a set amount of time you use it for as
long as you need it and then you get rid
of it and so rather than a checkmark for
no contracts I'm just gonna put a little
X there you only use it to when you need
it it's on demand and then the last
piece and this is probably the most
important as the service offerings are
self service that means that you can go
out to a website you punch in your
information your payment details click
the Go button and that as a service
offering is going to be provisioned and
delivered to you it's not something that
takes days or weeks or months to set up
and configure it's one that can be
provided in minutes or hours thanks for
stopping by today if you have any
questions please drop us a line below in
the comments if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please do
hit that like and subscribe button that
way we know you're interested in it and
don't forget you can always get started
and cloud at no cost by signing up for a
free IBM cloud account at cloud ibm.com